WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS SEEK
AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
WE HAD A $100,000 LOSS
THAT YEAR.
WHOA!
IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
PARTY SHIRT!
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
IT'S REALLY GOOD.
Both: AH! [ LAUGHING ]
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
HERE'S MY OFFER,
AND IT EXCLUDES ROBERT.
BARBARA WRITES
ON A STONE TABLET.
BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS MUST GET
THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
$200,000...
FOR THE ENTIRE BUSINESS.
WOW.
ARE YOU NUTS?
THIS IS A PIECE OF CRAP.
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE BUSINESS
EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN WENT FROM
WAITING TABLES IN MANHATTAN
TO BUILDING THE CITY'S PREMIER
$2 BILLION REAL ESTATE EMPIRE.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED OVER
400 PRODUCTS, GROSSING OVER
A HALF A BILLION DOLLARS
IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN, RENOWNED
BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
♪♪♪
FIRST INTO THE TANK
ARE ENTREPRENEURS
WITH A BETTER WAY
TO BAKE FROM SCRATCH.
HELLO. MY NAME IS LEAH.
AND I AM TAYA.
WE ARE TWO MOMS
FROM PORTLAND, OREGON,
AND TOGETHER WE CREATED...
Both: SCRATCH & GRAIN
BAKING COMPANY!
WE ARE HERE SEEKING
$150,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 20% EQUITY
OF OUR BUSINESS.
CURRENTLY, BAKING AT HOME
IS A VERY FLAWED PRODUCTION.
RIGHT. YOU EITHER HAVE
THAT MYSTERY BAG-O'-MIX
OR THAT QUESTIONABLE
TUBE OF DOUGH.
I CAN'T PRONOUNCE
THE INGREDIENTS
ON ANY OF THOSE LABELS, AND THEY
NEVER TASTE QUITE RIGHT.
ALTERNATIVELY, YOU CAN
SPEND HOURS UPON HOURS
BAKING FROM SCRATCH
AT HOME.
WHO HAS THE TIME AND MONEY
FOR THAT?
RIGHT?
RIGHT.
SINCE THERE CURRENTLY IS
NO GOOD OPTION
ON THE MARKET TO MAKE DELICIOUS
HOMEMADE BAKED COOKIES...
SO WE CREATED...
Both: THE COOKIE KIT!
♪ TA-DA ♪
OUR COOKIE KITS MAKE
HOMEMADE BAKING EASY AND FUN.
WE INDIVIDUALLY PACKAGE,
LABEL, NUMBER, AND COLOR-CODE
EACH INGREDIENT SEPARATELY,
MAKING HOMEMADE BAKING
FOOLPROOF.
SO ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS SUPPLY
THE BUTTER AND THE EGG...
AND WE PROVIDE THE REST.
PLUS, THESE COOKIE KITS
INTENTIONALLY MAKE
ONE LARGE COOKIE SHEET
OF 9 TO 12 BIG COOKIES
INSTEAD OF 40.
[ Singsongy ]
AND THEY TASTE AMAZING!
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO, SHARKS, WHO IS
EXCITED ABOUT THE COOKIE KIT
AND WANTS TO JUMP
IN THIS COOKIE JAR WITH US?
WHAT DO THEY TASTE LIKE?
[ LAUGHTER ]
WELL, LET US SHOW YOU!
WE'RE VERY HUNGRY SHARKS.
SO, TAKE A TRAY OF COOKIES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
TAYA, WHAT FLAVORS DO WE HAVE?
WELL, WE HAVE
SIX DIFFERENT FLAVORS.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE
CHOCOLATE CHIP,
OATMEAL RAISIN,
AND CLASSIC SUGAR,
AND THEN THREE OF OUR SIX
ARE ACTUALLY GLUTEN-FREE.
MMM.
THIS IS MY FAVORITE,
AND I HAVEN'T TRIED THE OTHERS.
WHAT IS IT?
IT'S OUT OF THIS WORLD.
OATMEAL RAISIN.
YES!
IT'S LIKE REAL OATMEAL.
THAT'S MY FAVORITE.
TAYA, I GOTTA BE HONEST
WITH YOU.
I DON'T KNOW.
I'M GONNA EAT ANOTHER
FIVE OR SIX
BEFORE I MAKE UP MY MIND.
YEAH, YOU WANNA TASTE SOME MORE.
IT IS INCREDIBLE.
THANK YOU.
WOW.
IT'S REALLY GOOD.
Both: AH! [ LAUGHING ]
IT'S A HEALTHIER COOKIE,
RIGHT?
YES, IT IS.
BECAUSE YOU'RE USING
WHOLE WHEAT FLOUR,
YOU'RE USING FLAX SEEDS,
ORGANIC SUGAR.
SO YOUR MARKET, REALLY,
IS, LIKE, WHOLE FOODS
OR PLACES THAT --
IT IS. THAT'S WHERE
WE'RE CURRENTLY AT.
WE'RE CURRENTLY IN ABOUT
220 LOCATIONS,
INCLUDING WHOLE FOODS --
UM, SUR LA TABLE.
WE'RE IN ALL 120
OF THEIR LOCATIONS.
AND HOW DID YOU EVEN
COME UP WITH THE IDEA?
YOU KNOW, I HAVE TWO DAUGHTERS,
AND ONE OF THEM
CAME TO ME AND SAID, "I WANT TO
MAKE HOMEMADE COOKIES."
SO I WENT TO THE STORE,
I SPENT $40 ON THE INGREDIENTS,
CAME HOME AND SPENT THREE HOURS
MEASURING, BAKING, AND CLEANING.
AND THE MOST FRUSTRATING PART
FOR ME IS I FELT WASTEFUL,
BECAUSE I BARELY USED
ANY OF THOSE INGREDIENTS.
AND I WAS LIKE, YOU KNOW
WHAT WOULD BE GREAT?
IF THERE SOME KIND OF A KIT
THAT HAD
THE BEST INGREDIENTS,
FIGURED OUT FOR ME,
SO IT STILL WAS AN ACTIVITY
TO DO AND STILL FUN,
BUT I DIDN'T HAVE TO GO
AND BUY ALL THE INGREDIENTS,
AND I DIDN'T WANT 40 COOKIES
AT THE END OF IT, EITHER.
TAYA, WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
OUR CURRENT SALES SINCE
INCEPTION 14 MONTHS AGO --
$52,000.
TAYA, IT SEEMS LOW TO ME.
YOU KNOW, IT IS, AND...
WE HAD EXPERIENCED A LOT
OF PRODUCTION PROBLEMS.
SO WHEN WE STARTED
THIS BUSINESS,
WE PACKAGED EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THOSE INGREDIENTS BY HAND.
WE STILL HAND-LABEL
EACH ONE OF THOSE BAGS.
SO WE NEED TO AUTOMATE
OUR PROCESS.
TAYA, YOU'RE SELLING IT
FOR HOW MUCH?
THE RETAIL IS
BETWEEN $7 AND $12,
DEPENDING ON THE STORE
THAT YOU BUY THEM FROM.
AND WHAT'S YOUR COST?
AND WHAT DOES IT COST
TO MAKE ONE?
OUR ALL-IN COST...
ALL-IN.
...WITH OUR OVERHEAD
AND EVERYTHING
IS $3.89 CURRENTLY.
OHH!
YEAH, THAT'S
OUR PROBLEM, TOO.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE.
OOH.
OH!
NOW THE THING THAT WE'VE ALWAYS
LIKED ABOUT THIS BUSINESS
IS THAT IT IS SCALABLE.
SO WE'VE ALWAYS KNOWN
THAT WE CAN GET MACHINERY --
OKAY, LET'S SCALE IT.
LET'S SAY YOU GET
YOUR $150,000.
MM-HMM.
WHAT IS THE NEW MODEL?
'CAUSE THOSE MARGINS SUCK.
THE MACHINES THAT WE WANT
WOULD BE ABLE TO PRODUCE
AT LEAST 50,000
8 HOURS A DAY...
WHAT COST?
...FIVE DAYS A WEEK.
INCLUDING OVERHEAD,
WHAT COST?
$2.15.
HOW MUCH OF YOUR PRODUCT
DO YOU SELL ONLINE?
IT'S NOT EVEN 10%.
WHY?
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT IS?
BECAUSE IT COSTS $5
TO SHIP A BOX.
WHO IS GONNA BUY A PRODUCT
FOR $8,
LET'S JUST SAY, FOR $5?
THAT IS A REALLY, REALLY
GOOD POINT.
YOU KNOW, ONE THING THAT
WOULD REALLY CUT DOWN
ON COSTS FOR YOU TREMENDOUSLY
IS IF EVERYTHING
WERE IN ONE BAG.
LIKE, YOU KNOW, EVERYTHING'S
MIXED IN AND IT'S LAYERED.
THAT'LL CUT DOWN
YOUR SHIPPING COSTS, TOO.
I'M JUST SAYING --
YOU DON'T LIKE IT, LEAH.
I DON'T LIKE IT, BECAUSE
THE REASON WE DID THIS --
THERE IS A REASON.
BECAUSE WE WANTED YOU TO KNOW
WHAT'S IN YOUR FOOD.
AND IT DOES MATTER. LIKE, BAKING
FROM SCRATCH IS DIFFERENT.
YOU PUT YOUR EGG
AND YOUR BUTTER AND YOUR SUGAR
AND YOU STIR IT REALLY WELL,
AND THAT EMULSIFIES IT.
AND THEN YOU ADD IN YOUR --
YOUR FLOURS,
AND THAT WAY YOU DON'T
OVER-STIR YOUR FLOUR.
YOU'RE SAYING --
YOU'RE SAYING...
THE PROCESS.
THAT YOU HAVE TO DO THEM
IN DIFFERENT TIERS.
RIGHT, EXACTLY.
ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE
WHAT MAKES THAT COOKIE
WAY BETTER THAN ANY OTHER
PACKAGED --
I AGREE WITH YOU.
I GET THAT, BUT I'M REALLY
ON THE FENCE WITH YOU,
BECAUSE THE WHOLE BUSINESS
IS ABOUT GETTING
YOUR COST OF GOODS IN THIS
PACKAGE DOWN TO AROUND $1.70.
RIGHT.
GUYS, LET ME SIMPLIFY THINGS
FOR EVERYBODY.
MY IDEA OF BAKING IS GOING...
[ SNIFFS ]
"THAT SMELLS GOOD."
THAT'S GOOD.
WHOMP! RIGHT?
WELL, LOOK AT --
HE'S GOT AN EMPTY PLATE.
TOTALLY GONE.
YAY! YEAH!
I HATED THEM, RIGHT?
YEAH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
UM, BUT...
I JUST HAVE NO CLUE,
SO I'M OUT.
OKAY.
I'D LIKE TO KNOW A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THE TWO OF YOU.
WHAT'S YOUR BACKGROUND?
UM, I CAN TELL YOU THE STORY
HOW WE STARTED.
IT'S KIND OF FUNNY.
UM, I HAD THIS BAD EXPERIENCE
BAKING WITH MY CHILDREN,
AND I HAVE THIS
GO-GETTER NEIGHBOR,
AND I, UM,
I KNEW SHE WANTED
TO START A BUSINESS.
SO I ACTUALLY SENT HER
THIS RANDOM TEXT MESSAGE
AND SAID, "HEY, UH, YOU WANT
TO START THIS BUSINESS
50/50 WITH ME?"
AND I ACTUALLY SPENT
10 YEARS
IN THE SECURITIES FINANCE
INDUSTRY.
WHEN I HAD MY FIRST CHILD,
I DECIDED
I JUST WASN'T GONNA PUT IN
18 HOURS FOR SOMEBODY ELSE
WITH NO LONG-TERM PAYOFF,
SO I ALWAYS WORK.
I'M THE HARDEST WORKER
YOU'LL EVER MEET.
AND IF I'M GONNA PUT IN
THAT TIME, THERE BETTER BE
A BETTER REWARD
AT THE END OF IT, SO...
OH, A CAPITALIST. I LOVE YOU.
WHAT WERE YOU SELLING
IN THE SECURITIES INDUSTRY?
UH, I WAS ACTUALLY
A FIXED INCOME TRADER,
SO BONDS, ANY KIND OF
FIXED INCOME SECURITY.
REALLY?
NOW HE REALLY LIKES YOU.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT NOW YOU'RE WORKING EVEN MORE
HOURS AND MAKING NO MONEY,
'CAUSE YOUR MARGINS SUCK.
I KNOW, BUT THERE'S
A LONG-TERM PAYOFF ON THIS.
THE FIRST THING THAT CAME
TO MY MIND WAS
THAT THERE ARE SO MANY
OTHER COOKIES OUT THERE
WHERE YOU CAN BAKE THEM
YOURSELF AT HOME.
AND I HATE TO SAY THAT,
BECAUSE I REALLY LIKE YOU,
BUT I THOUGHT,
THIS IS JUST SO COMPETITIVE.
SO FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
Leah: THANK YOU.
I DON'T DOUBT YOUR ABILITY
TO, UM, SELL.
I THINK YOU'RE --
YOU'RE BOTH HUSTLING
IN THE MOST POSITIVE WAY.
I LOVE THE FACT
YOU LEFT AN INDUSTRY
THAT YOU DIDN'T HAVE
PASSION FOR,
AND YOU'RE DOING IT
FOR YOURSELF.
YOU KNOW --
RIGHT. WE ARE WORKING
SO HARD.
YEAH, YOU'RE WORKING SUPER HARD.
IT'S VERY ADMIRABLE.
YOU'RE WORKING ALL THE TIME.
YOU KNOW, I HONESTLY
WAS RAISED...
[ Voice breaking ]
BY A SINGLE MOM
THAT STRUGGLED WITH
DRUG ADDICTION HER WHOLE LIFE,
AND I WORKED MY WAY OUT.
I, UH...SORRY, I'M PREGNANT,
WHICH IS THE ONLY REASON
I'M, LIKE, CRYING.
NO PROBLEM AT ALL. NO PROBLEM.
AND THAT'S WHAT ACTUALLY
GAVE ME MY MOTIVATION
TO BE WHERE I AM,
IS FROM SEEING MY MOTHER,
WHO'S MADE
A LOT OF BAD DECISIONS
AND PUT US IN A LOT
OF BAD SITUATIONS.
AND SO IT'S BEEN MY MOTIVATION
TO NEVER GO THROUGH THAT
AND TO NEVER PUT MY OWN FAMILY
THROUGH IT.
[ CRIES ] AND I --
[ LAUGHS ]
THANK YOU.
OH.
AND WE DID IT ALL 'CAUSE
WE BELIEVE IN THE PRODUCT,
WE BELIEVE IN THE BUSINESS.
[ SNIFFLES ]
BUT LET ME, UH, LET ME
MAKE A STATEMENT HERE, JUST --
UNLESS YOU GET THE PRODUCTION
DOWN TO $1.70,
YOU'LL GO OUT OF BUSINESS,
I'M SORRY.
WE CAN CRY ALL WE WANT,
BUT THAT'S THE TRUTH.
[ CHUCKLES ]
OKAY? YOU WILL NEVER MAKE --
DON'T MAKE A PREGNANT GIRL
CRY ANY MORE.
NO, I GET IT. I GET THAT --
[ LAUGHTER ]
JUST -- AND SO, YOU --
AND I'M SURE THERE'S A WAY
FOR YOU TO DO THAT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS
RIGHT NOW,
BUT YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO GET
THERE PRETTY QUICKLY,
OR YOU'RE GOING TO ZERO.
GOOD LUCK TO YOU. I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANKS.
ALL RIGHT, A COUPLE
OF THOUGHTS.
YES.
HONESTLY, WHEN I HEARD
SCRATCH & GRAIN,
I REALLY THOUGHT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT SCRATCHING.
SHE'S RIGHT.
I KNOW YOU MEANT
"FROM SCRATCH,"
BUT I THINK WHEN
IT'S THE FIRST WORD,
I DIDN'T QUITE GET THAT,
AND I THINK
A TYPICAL CONSUMER WOULD NOT.
I ALSO WISH YOU HAD
COME IN HERE AND SAID,
"HEY, WE'RE LOOKING
FOR $50,000."
NO PROBLEM. I WOULD HAVE
TAKEN A CHANCE.
$150,000 IS WAY TOO MUCH.
TOO RISKY.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO GET AROUND
THE $150,000.
WELL, I HAVE A WAY TO GET
AROUND THAT.
HOW?
ALL THE TIME I'VE BEEN UP HERE,
I'VE NEVER LOST MONEY
IN SOMEBODY WHO DEEPLY BELIEVES
IN WHAT THEY'RE DOING
AND SEES IT AS SOMETHING GREATER
THAN JUST MAKING A BUCK.
YOU'VE GOT THAT IN SPADES.
HOWEVER, THE CATEGORY
IS PROBABLY
A LITTLE TOO SMALL
FOR ME TODAY.
THIS IS DEFINITELY
A BARBARA CATEGORY
SHE UNDERSTANDS.
OH, THANK YOU.
I'M SO COMPLIMENTED.
IT IS A COMPLIMENT.
HER ONLY OBJECTION WAS
IT'S TOO MUCH OF AN ASK.
I'LL GIVE YOU $150,000 FOR 40%
AS LONG AS YOU CAN CONVINCE
BARBARA TO COME IN
FOR HALF OF IT.
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
TAYA AND LEAH HAVE
AN OFFER FROM ROBERT,
BUT IT'S FOR TWICE
THE EQUITY THEY'RE OFFERING,
AND THEY HAVE TO CONVINCE
BARBARA TO GO IN ON THE DEAL.
I WANT TO PARTICIPATE,
BUT BARBARA CAN ADD
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF VALUE
TO THIS CATEGORY.
TELL ME THAT AGAIN, ROBERT.
IN FACT, HERE'S MY OFFER
AND IT EXCLUDES ROBERT.
I'LL GIVE YOU $150,000
AS A LINE OF CREDIT,
BUT I STILL GET 20% EQUITY.
BARBARA, THAT DOESN'T MAKE
ANY SENSE!
OF COURSE IT MAKES SENSE.
IT MAKES TOTAL SENSE.
WITH MY OFFER, YOU HAVE TO
PUT UP HALF THE MONEY
AND GET THE SAME EQUITY.
Kevin: YEAH, IT'S CRAZY.
BUT I DON'T WANT YOU
IN THE DEAL.
ALL RIGHT.
Mark: AND IT'S NOT FAIR
TO TAKE 40%.
NO FAIR -- HE'S A LOVELY GUY,
BUT HE IS A PAIN IN THE ASS
WHEN YOU TRY TO REACH HIM.
AND THAT'S NOT ANY FUN.
BUH-BAM!
I LIKE TO MAKE ALL THE DECISIONS
WITH MY ENTREPRENEURS,
SEE WHAT THEY THINK,
BANG, MOVE QUICKLY.
AND BESIDES WHICH --
ROBERT, BARBARA JUST
THREW YOU UNDER A BUS.
I'M NOT GONNA ARGUE WITH HER.
BARBARA WRITES
ON A STONE TABLET.
SO THAT IT'S --
[ LAUGHTER ]
I USE THIS FANCY THING
CALLED E-MAIL.
LOOK, I -- SHE OBVIOUSLY
DOESN'T WANT ME IN THE DEAL.
I REALLY BELIEVED IN YOU GUYS.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
MAKING US AN OFFER
WITHOUT BARBARA?
TAYA, ALL OF A SUDDEN
YOU'RE NOT CRYING ANYMORE
AND YOU'VE GOT THIS NASTY
ELEMENT I REALLY LIKE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I-I'LL MAKE THE SAME OFFER
WITH OR WITHOUT BARBARA --
$150,000 FOR 40%.
OKAY.
LADIES, THE COOKIES ARE BURNING.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
[ LAUGHS ]
[ MOUTHS WORDS ]
ROBERT, WE WOULD ABSOLUTELY
LOVE TO ACCEPT YOUR OFFER,
BUT WE HAVE TO TAKE
BARBARA'S.
THERE WE GO, ROBERT.
WHOO-HOO!
CAN'T SAY NO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SORRY, BIG BOY. YOU'RE EVEN
SMARTER THAN I THOUGHT.
BARBARA!
[ LAUGHING ]
Taya and Leah: THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BYE.
BYE.
I LIKE THOSE WOMEN.
I'M HAPPY THEY GOT A DEAL.
[ Voice breaking ] WE'VE JUST
BOTH PUT OUR HEART AND OUR SOUL
INTO THIS BUSINESS,
SO THIS IS A GREAT DAY.
I'M SO THANKFUL AND HAPPY
THAT WE GOT A DEAL.
I'M VERY HAPPY.
IN SEASON 5, FORMER
C.I.A. AGENT JASON HANSON
REVEALED THE TRICKS
OF THE TRADE
AS PART OF HIS SURVIVAL
TECHNIQUE TRAINING BUSINESS,
SPY ESCAPE AND EVASION.
OH, MY GOD!
$150,000 FOR 45%.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S DO IT.
DONE.
LET'S SEE WHAT HE'S
UP TO NOW.
SINCE "SHARK TANK,"
IT HAS BEEN
A WILD
AND RIDICULOUSLY FUN RIDE.
WITH DAYMOND'S INVESTMENT,
I'VE CONSTRUCTED
MY 320-ACRE PROPERTY
CALLED SPY RANCH HERE IN UTAH.
ORIGINALLY, DAYMOND WAS AGAINST
OPENING UP SPY RANCH
HERE IN UTAH, BUT ONCE
I SHOWED HIM THE NUMBERS
AND HE SAW THE POTENTIAL,
HE'S 100% BACKING IT.
WE TEACH COURSES
FROM EVASIVE DRIVING
TO FIREARMS TRAINING
TO HAND-TO-HAND SELF-DEFENSE.
[ GRUNTS ]
THE YEAR BEFORE "SHARK TANK,"
I HAD $306,000 IN SALES.
NOW, IN JUST EIGHT MONTHS,
I'VE GOT ALMOST $2 MILLION
IN SALES.
WE'VE SECURED A ROYALTY DEAL
FOR SEVERAL OF MY PRODUCTS,
A SPY FLASHLIGHT,
WE HAVE A TACTICAL PEN,
AND WE HAVE AN ESCAPE
AND EVASION BELT,
WHICH IS A SPECIAL GUN BELT
THAT HAS
SECRET HIDDEN COMPARTMENTS
FOR SURVIVAL GEAR.
THE QUESTIONS YOU DON'T ASK MAY
COST YOU YOUR LIFE ONE DAY.
WHEN I CAME ON "SHARK TANK,"
I LACKED
A TON OF BUSINESS KNOWLEDGE
AND I NEEDED A SHARK.
GETTING THAT DEAL WITH DAYMOND
HAS CHANGED MY LIFE.
I LOVE THESE THINGS --
WHAT'S UP?
HEY!
HOW YOU DOING?
Daymond: I CAME TO SPY RANCH
TODAY TO CHECK IN ON JASON,
CHECK OUT THE AMAZING PROPERTY,
GET A LITTLE TRAINING,
AND OFFICIALLY BECOME A SPY.
KEEP GOING, KEEP GOING,
KEEP GOING.
YOU HAVE TO BE PERFECT.
YES!
[ TIRES SCREECH ]
WHOO! PERFECT!
Daymond: SPY RANCH IS AMAZING.
IT IS IN THE MIDDLE OF NOWHERE.
YOU CAN DO EVERYTHING HERE
FROM TACTICAL TRAINING,
TARGET PRACTICE --
THE POSSIBILITIES ARE ENDLESS.
[ GUNFIRE ]
SHOOT!
THIS CAN BE A FRANCHISE
WHERE YOU CAN HAVE ONE
IN EVERY CITY
IN EVERY SINGLE STATE.
I AM OFFICIALLY A SPY!
YOU ARE THE BEST!
AWESOME.
♪♪♪
NEXT UP IS A CLEANING SOLUTION
FOR THOSE HARD-TO-REACH PARTS.
HELLO, SHARKS.
I'M JUSTIN KOEHNEKE.
AND I'M SETH FRIEDMAN,
AND WE ARE THE CREATORS
OF BOTTLE BRIGHT.
WE'RE HERE TODAY SEEKING
$75,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 15%
OF OUR COMPANY.
SHARKS, THERE ARE ALL KINDS
OF PORTABLE DRINKING CONTAINERS
THAT MAKE OUR LIVES EASIER.
THE PROBLEM IS, THEY DEVELOP
STAINS AND ODORS EASILY.
AND THE TYPICAL METHODS
FOR CLEANING THEM
JUST DON'T WORK WELL.
DISHWASHERS CAN'T SPRAY
INTO NARROW OPENINGS,
AND MANY DRINKING CONTAINERS
AREN'T DISHWASHER-SAFE.
CHLORINE BLEACH
AND OTHER HARSH CHEMICALS
ARE TOXIC AND DANGEROUS.
WE WERE FRUSTRATED BY
THE LACK OF SUITABLE METHODS
TO CLEAN OUR PORTABLE
DRINKWEAR.
WE WERE LOOKING FOR A SOLUTION
THAT WAS EASY TO USE,
SAFE, AND EFFECTIVE.
THAT'S WHY WE CREATED
BOTTLE BRIGHT.
BOTTLE BRIGHT IS AN EFFERVESCENT
CLEANING TABLET
THAT IS AMAZING
AT REMOVING STAINS AND ODORS
FROM PORTABLE DRINKWEAR.
AND IT'S SO EASY TO USE.
SIMPLY FILL YOUR BOTTLE
WITH WATER,
DROP IN A BOTTLE BRIGHT TABLET,
AND LET IT GO TO WORK.
THEN DISCARD THE SOLUTION,
GIVE IT A QUICK RINSE,
AND YOUR BOTTLE IS FRESH
AND CLEAN.
SHARKS, WE ARE COMMITTED
TO MAKING BOTTLE BRIGHT
A HOUSEHOLD NAME.
WE NEED YOUR EXPERTISE
IN GETTING OUR UNIQUE PRODUCT
INTO THE HANDS
OF CONSUMERS.
SO, WHO WOULD LIKE
TO JOIN US
IN SOLVING THE DIRTY BOTTLE
DILEMMA?
LET ME PASS OUT SOME SAMPLES
FOR YOU TO LOOK AT.
IT'S LIKE EFFERDENT
FOR YOUR BOTTLE. [ LAUGHS ]
I THINK THE BIGGEST
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN IT
AND SOMETHING LIKE
EFFERDENT
IS THIS IS AN ALL-NATURAL
PRODUCT.
Lori: ALL-NATURAL.
WHAT'S IN THAT TABLET?
TH-THEY'RE ALL-NATURAL
INGREDIENTS,
BUT THEY'RE ALL MINERAL-BASED
OR ORGANIC-BASED.
DOES IT HAVE ANY ODOR
WHEN I -- AFTERWARDS?
NONE.
ABSOLUTELY NO ODOR
OR RESIDUAL SMELL.
GUYS, I'M GONNA BET THAT
YOU HAVE VERY LITTLE SALES
'CAUSE NOBODY GIVES A DAMN.
[ LAUGHS ] YEAH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I-I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
GIVE A DAMN,
BUT WE HAVE VERY LITTLE SALES.
SO HALF YOUR COMMENT IS CORRECT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
TELL US ABOUT YOUR SALES.
Kevin: WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
UM, LAST YEAR WE DID
$110,000.
THIS YEAR WE'RE
AT $85,000.
WELL, THAT'S NOT "NO SALES."
THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
SETH, HOW LONG
HAVE YOU BEEN DOING IT?
UH, WE STARTED
THREE YEARS AGO.
WE HAVE
PRIVATE LABEL CUSTOMERS.
WE'RE DEALING WITH TWO
VERY LARGE COMPANIES
THAT WE'RE NOW PRIVATE-LABELING
THIS SAME FORMULA FOR.
I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR.
WHEN YOU PRIVATE-LABEL IT,
THERE'S NO BRAND FOR YOU.
THEY'RE SIMPLY USING IT
AS PART OF THEIR PRODUCT.
SO I GO TO THEM,
I BUY THE PRODUCT.
YOU COME ALONG WITH IT.
IS THAT RIGHT?
YEAH, WE MANUFACTURE FOR THEM.
IT'S UNDER THEIR BRAND.
AND I BET YOU'RE MAKING HUNDREDS
OF DOLLARS DOING THAT.
[ LAUGHING ]
WELL, WHY DON'T WE TALK ABOUT --
WHAT DOES THE PRODUCT COST?
THE PRODUCT HAS GREAT MARGINS.
YES.
WHAT DOES IT COST, AND WHAT
DO YOU SELL IT FOR?
SO WE BUILD THE -- WE BUILD
THE 10-PACK POUCH
RIGHT THERE FOR 79 CENTS.
WE WHOLESALE IT FOR $2.99
TO RETAIL.
AND -- AND -- AND THEN THEY
SELL IT FOR $5.99.
WHAT'S THE REST OF YOUR STORY?
LIKE, WHY DID YOU
COME UP WITH THIS?
SURE.
SO WE'RE MOUNTAIN BIKERS.
AND WE FINISHED A DAY
OF MOUNTAIN BIKING.
WE USE HYDRATION PACKS
MUCH LIKE YOU SEE THERE
WITH THE HOSE, AND I FINISHED
THAT RIDE THAT DAY,
PULLED UP TO THE TRAIL HEAD
AND SAID TO JUSTIN,
"THIS THING TASTES DISGUSTING."
'CAUSE THEY'RE IMPOSSIBLE
TO CLEAN.
SO WE HAD THAT ISSUE.
I SAID TO JUSTIN,
"I'M LEADING
A HEALTHY LIFESTYLE,
"AND I'M DUMPING BLEACH
IN HERE.
"AND NOW IT TASTES LIKE
A SWIMMING POOL
"AND I'M KILLING MYSELF.
LET'S COME UP WITH
AN ALL-NATURAL SOLUTION."
SO JUST TO GO BACK, YOU DID
$110,000 IN SALES.
MM-HMM.
PRIVATE LABEL TO TWO COMPANIES.
YES.
DID YOU MAKE ANY MONEY
ON THAT?
WE DID NOT. WE HAD A ROUGH 2013,
TO BE PERFECTLY HONEST WITH YOU.
OKAY. WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
WE HAD A $100,000 LOSS
THAT YEAR.
WHOA!
LAST YEAR, ABOUT, UH,
JULY 2013,
WE DID A LARGE RUN FOR ONE OF
OUR PRIVATE LABEL COMPANIES.
AND WE WERE TRYING TO PUSH
THE BOUNDARIES
OF ECOLOGICAL PACKAGING.
THEY WANTED A FILM THAT WAS
BIODEGRADABLE.
WE SENT THEM
A LARGE AMOUNT OF PRODUCT,
AND THERE WAS MOISTURE VAPOR
THAT WAS STARTING TO
PENETRATE THROUGH THE PRODUCT
AND DEGRADE THE TABLETS.
SO YOU DID A RECALL?
YOU TOOK IT BACK?
WE REPLACED IT. WE TOOK IT BACK.
WE THOUGHT IT WOULD BE BEST
TO TAKE THE ENTIRE THING BACK --
AND YOU LOST $100,000
ON THAT.
PAINFUL YEAR.
YOU'RE VERY LUCKY
YOU'VE MET ME TODAY,
AND I'M GONNA TELL YOU WHY.
I'M ALSO A CLEANER.
I'M THE WONDERFUL CLEANER.
I CLEAN REALLY BAD IDEAS
RIGHT OUT OF THE SHARK TANK,
AND THIS FALLS UNDER
THAT CATEGORY.
YOU SPENT OVER THREE YEARS
DOING THIS,
IT'S STILL NOT PROFITABLE,
AND YET YOU CLAIM
YOU'RE ENTREPRENEURS.
AT SOME POINT,
A SUCCESSFUL ENTREPRENEUR KNOWS
THEY HAVE A LOSER,
AND THEY SHOOT IT.
KEVIN, I SENSE YOU'RE GONNA
MAKE AN OFFER.
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU AN OFFER
TO THINK IT THROUGH,
LEAVE HERE, AND SHOOT IT.
BY THE WAY, I'M OUT.
SETH, HERE'S MY -- HERE'S
MY CHALLENGE WITH IT. LOOK.
YOU HAVEN'T PROVEN ANY DEMAND.
I THINK ANYBODY THAT TRULY CARES
ENOUGH ABOUT CLEANING
THEIR WATER BOTTLE
ALREADY HAS AN OPTION.
YOU'RE DOING IT BETTER
POTENTIALLY,
BUT THAT IS GONNA BE
A REAL CHALLENGE
TO GET THAT CONSUMER
TO CARE THAT MUCH MORE.
I -- WHEN YOU'RE SPENDING $40 --
I DON'T SEE THE DIRECTION.
I UNDERSTAND.
I'M OUT.
WHAT WAS YOUR PLAN TO DO
WITH THE $75,000?
WHY DO YOU NEED IT?
$75,000 WE FEEL
IS HELPFUL FOR ADMINISTRATION.
TO ME, THE WORST WASTE OF MONEY
IS FOR IT TO GO
TO ADMINISTRATION
WHEN YOU'VE GOT TWO PEOPLE THAT
SHOULD BE REAL FIRECRACKERS
OUT THERE, YOU KNOW,
BURNING THE MIDNIGHT OIL,
WORKING MORNING, NOON,
AND NIGHT TO MAKE IT HAPPEN.
IF YOU WERE TO INVEST WITH US,
I'D BE COMPLETELY OPEN-MINDED
TO ANY IDEA YOU HAD AND WHAT
WE SHOULD DO WITH THAT MONEY.
THERE'S A LARGER ISSUE HERE
THAT IS VERY DISTURBING TO ME.
I THINK YOU CREATED A...
AN ENORMOUS MISTRUST
IN MY MIND WHEN YOU SAID
YOU LOST $100,000 IN YEAR 3.
NOTHING'S WRONG WITH LOSING
$100,000 IN YEAR 1,
BUT THEN EVERYBODY LIKES TO SEE
SALES START TO GET SOME TRACTION
AND GO UP.
I'M OUT.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
YOU HAD A GREAT IDEA.
RIGHT?
YOU TURNED IT INTO WHAT LOOKS
LIKE A GOOD PRODUCT.
BUT WHAT YOU DON'T HAVE
IS A COMPANY.
AND WHAT'S EVEN WORSE IS
YOU COME ACROSS
AS BEING DESPERATE.
RIGHT? EVERYTHING
THAT YOU'VE SAID
IS LIKE YOU'RE DROWNING
AND YOU'RE TRYING TO PUSH
FOR A LIFELINE.
JUST TO BE CLEAR, IT'S NOT
DESPERATION, IT'S PASSION.
WE HAVE PASSION
FOR THIS PRODUCT.
I CAN TELL THE DIFFERENCE.
AND WHEN I SENSE DESPERATION,
THAT'S A HUGE NEGATIVE.
I DON'T INVEST IN DESPERATION.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
I DON'T AGREE WITH A LOT OF
THE COMMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE UP HERE.
UM, I THINK THAT THIS IS
A SOLUTION TO A BIG PROBLEM.
SO I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
AN OFFER.
ARE YOU KIDDING?
I HAVE A BIG INITIATIVE WITH
BED BATH & BEYOND RIGHT NOW,
AND I CAN HELP YOU A GREAT DEAL
WITH THAT
AND WITH MANY OTHER RETAILERS
TO GET IN.
SO HERE'S MY OFFER.
I'M GONNA OFFER YOU
THE $75,000,
BUT I WANT 35%
AND A CONDITION THAT THE MONEY
WILL GO TOWARDS FUNDING
ALL THE PURCHASE ORDERS.
I DON'T WANT IT TO GO TO ADMIN.
AND I KNOW I HAVE DIRECT
TARGETS FOR US TO GET THIS IN.
IN RETAIL AND ON QVC,
THIS WILL HELP TO GIVE
YOURSELF FREE ADVERTISING
SO PEOPLE KNOW WHAT
THE PRODUCT IS
WHEN THEY WALK INTO
BED BATH & BEYOND
AND THEY SEE IT.
SO THAT'S MY OFFER.
THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE THE OFFER.
THANK YOU. YEAH,
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH.
WOULD -- WOULD YOU BE WILLING
TO DO 25%?
ARE YOU KIDDING?
I WOULD BE WILLING TO DO
33 AND 1/3.
FINAL OFFER.
SOUNDS GOOD, LORI.
YOU GOT YOURSELF A DEAL.
AWESOME.
Mark: CONGRATS, GUYS.
Robert:
SHE BELIEVED IN THE PRODUCT.
I HAVE SEEN ALL THE CONTAINERS
THAT PEOPLE ARE CRYING ABOUT.
YES. THERE --
THERE ARE A LOT OF THEM
OUT THERE.
QVC SELLS HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF THESE.
WE'RE GONNA CLEAN A LOT
OF BOTTLES.
WE ARE GONNA DO
A GREAT BUSINESS.
THANK YOU. VERY GOOD
TO MEET YOU ALL.
THANKS, GUYS.
YEAH!
YEAH! LORI!
THAT WAS IT! THAT WAS
WHO WE WANTED.
LORI! YEAH.
YOU GET ON THAT CARPET,
AND IT'S YOUR BIG MOMENT,
AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN
KEVIN LOOKS AT YOU
AND HE SAYS,
"THIS IS A PIECE OF CRAP."
LORI, IT'S OKAY. YOU'RE GONNA
MAKE SOME MISTAKES.
THIS WAS ONE OF THEM.
[ LAUGHS ]
♪♪♪
NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A PRODUCT DESIGNED
FOR KIDS TO EASILY CARRY
THEIR BELONGINGS.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL WOOLEY,
AND I'M THE CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER OF VESTPAKZ.
WELL, HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS ARTHUR GRAYER.
I AM THE OFFICIAL LICENSEE
OF THE VESTPAK.
I'M ASKING FOR $50,000
FOR EXCHANGE
FOR 10% OF MY COMPANY.
WE HAVE ADDED A NEW TWIST
TO THE COMMON VEST.
VESTPAKZ WAS INVENTED
BY MY DAUGHTER
WHEN SHE WAS IN 6th GRADE.
HER TEACHER GAVE HER
A SCIENCE PROJECT --
FIND A PROBLEM,
COME UP WITH A SOLUTION.
SHE THOUGHT,
"BACKPACKS ARE HEAVY."
SHE CREATED A NEW BACKPACK
THAT'S MORE COMFORTABLE,
CONVENIENT, AND STYLISH.
HUH.
INTRODUCING VESTPAK.
IT'S A VEST-PACK COMBINATION.
ITS FUNCTIONAL DESIGN HELPS
DISTRIBUTE THE WEIGHT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GREAT JOB MODELING.
A MODEL IN THE MAKING.
YOU KNOW, I'VE BEEN
IN THE BACKPACK BUSINESS
FOR OVER 30 YEARS,
AND I'VE NEVER SEEN
A PRODUCT LIKE THIS BEFORE.
REMEMBER, YOU CAN PUT
IMPORTANT STUFF UP FRONT,
LIKE...YOUR MONEY!
OKAY, SHARKS, WHO WANTS
TO START PUTTING
MONEY IN
YOUR FRONT POCKETS?
HOW MUCH MONEY DO YOU HAVE
IN SALES?
[ LAUGHS ]
JANUARY AND FEBRUARY
WE HAD APPROXIMATELY
$10,000 WORTH.
OOH.
THAT'S NOT A LOT OF MONEY!
YEAH. ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
MICHAEL, WHAT IS
THE RELATIONSHIP AGAIN?
YOU OWN THE RIGHTS
FOR THE PRODUCT.
RIGHT.
AND THEN YOU LICENSED IT
TO ARTHUR.
AND ONLY ARTHUR CAN SELL
THE PRODUCT.
IS THAT RIGHT?
THAT'S TRUE. THAT IS TRUE.
CAN WE SEE THE PRODUCT?
GUYS, COME ON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANKS, SWEETIE.
YEAH.
FOR ME, FOR ME.
I'LL TAKE THE LOLLIPOP.
THANK YOU.
OKAY. COME ON, KIDS.
Kevin: YEAH, IT'S BEST TO GET
RID OF THE KIDS
'CAUSE THINGS ARE ABOUT
TO GET UGLY.
Barbara: HA!
Mark: GOOD JOB, GUYS.
Arthur: GREAT JOB. GREAT JOB.
Lori: BYE.
ARTHUR, YOU BUY THE PRODUCT
THEN YOU PAY A FEE TO MICHAEL.
WHAT IS THAT FEE THAT YOU PAY
OFF EVERY PRODUCT?
I MAKE 6 1/2% ROYALTY.
AND HOW MUCH DO THESE
SELL FOR?
THAT ONE SELLS
FOR $14.88 RETAIL.
AND WHAT DID IT COST YOU
TO MAKE THAT?
THAT COST AROUND $4.75.
AND THE TOTAL SALES OVER
WHAT PERIOD OF TIME ARE WHAT?
WELL, WHAT HAPPENED WAS
LAST NOVEMBER WE SIGNED
A LICENSE AGREEMENT.
WE HAD IT IN A BIG BOX STORE
FOR JANUARY AND FEBRUARY.
WHICH ONE?
WALMART.
YOU HAD THIS AT WALMART?
YES.
Mark: HOW MANY STORES
WERE YOU IN?
75 STORES.
$10,000 IN SALES
IN 75 WALMARTS.
WELL, THE QUESTION NEXT --
WELL, THEY GAVE YOU A TEST.
AND WHAT HAPPENED?
THEY DELISTED IT
WHEN YOU DIDN'T SELL ANY?
I WOULD HAVE LOVED TO
GOTTEN IT OUT,
YOU KNOW, DURING HOLIDAY, BUT IT
DID GO OUT DURING JANUARY.
IS WALMART GOING TO RE-ORDER
AND SELL IT IN MORE STORES?
THAT'S WHAT I NEED TO SEE,
WHAT HAPPENS
DURING BACK TO SCHOOL.
WE'LL FIND OUT AT THAT TIME.
BUT, ARTHUR,
JUST PUT YOURSELF
IN MY SHOES FOR A MOMENT.
SURE.
YOU'RE IN WALMART.
YES.
LARGEST RETAILER IN THE WORLD.
YOU'RE IN 75 STORES, YOU'VE ONLY
DONE $10,000 IN SALES.
THAT SEEMS BAD TO ME.
Barbara: TELL US
WHAT WE'RE MISSING HERE.
WELL, THE THING IS --
TELL US WHY THIS IS
GOOD NEWS.
Robert: YEAH.
WELL, THIS IS VERY GOOD NEWS.
WHY?
THAT THEY'RE EVEN WILLING TO --
THAT THEY'RE WILLING TO,
YOU KNOW, TRY SOMETHING OUT.
CAN WE COME BACK AND LET ME
GIVE A LITTLE HISTORY?
AFTER MY DAUGHTER
HAD INVENTED IT,
SHE WON HER 6th GRADE
SCIENCE CLASS CONTEST.
THEN ANOTHER CONTEST CALLED
MILLION DOLLAR IDEA CHALLENGE
COMES UP,
AND SO IT WAS PUT ON
OPRAH WINFREY.
AND STILL YOU ONLY SOLD
$10,000?
NO, NO, NO, NO --
THIS IS NOT A GOOD STORY!
THIS WAS BACK IN 2003.
HOW OLD'S YOUR DAUGHTER NOW?
SHE'S 27.
[ LAUGHS HYSTERICALLY ]
REALLY?
MICHAEL, I THOUGHT THAT WAS
YOUR DAUGHTER.
OH, REALLY?
YEAH.
OH, MY GOSH.
YOU MADE IT SEEM LIKE
THIS JUST HAPPENED,
AND IT WAS A NEW PRODUCT
WITH ALL THIS MOMENTUM.
I DON'T KNOW --
WHAT DID I SAY TO MAKE --
WHEN YOU STARTED TALKING ABOUT
YOUR DAUGHTER IN 6th GRADE,
WE SEE THESE KIDS --
DIDN'T YOU GUYS THINK
THAT THIS JUST HAPPENED
RECENTLY?
YEAH. TOTALLY.
AND WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
WINNING THESE CONTESTS
AND GETTING THIS ATTENTION,
IT WAS LIKE IT WAS YESTERDAY.
WELL...
[ LAUGHS ] WHAT HAPPENED?
BUT -- BUT WE SEE --
[ LAUGHS ]
WHAT HAPPENED HERE?!
SHE WAS IN PRODUCT DEVELOPMENT.
IT TOOK A WHILE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WHY IS THERE THIS
HUGE BLOCK OF TIME
WHERE NOTHING MUCH HAPPENED?
I DIDN'T HAVE THE FUNDS
TO -- TO --
TO GO AND BUY
A LOT OF STOCK.
HOW OLD WAS YOUR DAUGHTER
IN 6th GRADE? 11?
AND SHE'S 27 NOW?
RIGHT.
RIGHT? SO THAT'S --
RIGHT, IT'S 16 YEARS.
[ LAUGHING ] 16 YEARS!
ALL RIGHT, I GUESS TH--
CAN YOU UNDERSTAND OUR GAP OF
CREDIBILITY OVER THAT 16 YEARS?
BUT IT WOULD HAVE BEEN OKAY
IF YOU WOULD HAVE
JUST TOLD US THAT.
NO, I UNDERS--
I UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE
COMING FROM, BUT --
Lori: ALL RIGHT,
HERE'S THE MAGIC QUESTION.
HOW MUCH HAS YOUR SALES BEEN...
SINCE SHE WAS IN 6th GRADE.
...IN THE LAST 16 YEARS?
BASICALLY, THE $10,000
FOR JANUARY AND FEBRUARY.
OKAY, GUYS, WHEN THIS PRODUCT
CAME OUT,
"MANDY" WAS NUMBER ONE, OKAY?
[ LAUGHTER ]
WE'LL START THERE.
SINCE THEN, NOTHING'S HAPPENED
UNTIL YOU PUT IT INTO WALMART.
WE STILL DON'T KNOW YET
IF IT'S GOING TO BE
DELISTED OR NOT.
YEAH.
WE'RE GONNA WAIT FOR
THE BACK TO SCHOOL SEASON.
ABSOLUTELY.
THAT WOULD BE AN IMPORTANT
PIECE OF INFORMATION,
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
IT'S WORTH $500,000
UNTIL I KNOW THAT WALMART
WANTS TO KEEP IT IN.
AND IN THE CASE OF THIS PRODUCT,
WHETHER WE GET TOGETHER NOW
OR IN ANOTHER DECADE,
WHO CARES?
IT'S JUST A BLIP
IN THE LONG DURATION
OF HOW LONG THIS THING'S
BEEN AROUND.
MAY I ADD SOMETHING NOW?
MY BET IS
IF I WENT TO THE SMITHSONIAN
AND WENT TO THE BACKPACK
MUSEUM...
IT'D BE THERE!
...I WOULD FIND THAT HERE.
ACTUALLY, UH, IT'S FUNNY
YOU MENTIONED THAT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
'CAUSE THEY HAVE INVITED US
FOR 2015 FOR THE EXHIBITS.
OKAY, I'M ABOUT TO SAY --
AND THIS IS SERIOUS --
I'M OUT.
MAY I SAY THAT THERE IS
A PROBLEM OUT THERE.
YOU GOTTA UNDERSTAND,
WITH SOME OF THE HEAVY BOOKS
AND STUFF LIKE THAT, AND IT DOES
DISTRIBUTE THE WEIGHT.
WE TESTED IT,
AND IT WAS LESS WEIGHT.
Robert: YOU KNOW, YOU SEEM
LIKE A GENUINE PERSON.
I DON'T THINK YOU CAME OUT HERE
TO MISLEAD US.
NO.
HERE'S MY CHALLENGE WITH IT.
FORGET THE 16 YEARS,
FORGET THE SONG "MANDY."
FORGET ALL THAT.
$10,000 IN SALES
FOR 75 STORES --
IT'S NOT A GOOD NUMBER.
IT TAKES TIME TO DEVELOP
SOME OF THESE THINGS.
I'M REALLY AT
THE BEGINNING STAGES.
I-I HEAR YOU, BUT $10,000
IN 75 STORES
IN THE LARGEST RETAILER
IN THE WORLD --
AND I ALSO HAVE A TEST GOING
INTO TOYS "R" US,
WHICH IS FAO SCHWARZ,
AS YOU KNOW.
I HAVE OTHER PEOPLE THAT ARE
GONNA BE TRYING IT, TOO.
THE NUMBERS DON'T LIE.
I'M OUT.
GUYS, I ACTUALLY LIKE
THE PRODUCT.
IT'S NOT BAD.
BUT WE INVEST
IN THE ENTREPRENEURS
AND WE INVEST IN THE COMPANY.
SURE.
AND THERE'S JUST A WHOLE LOT
OF QUESTION MARKS IN MY MIND.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
BUT THE GOOD NEWS IS,
BARBARA AND LORI
STILL AREN'T OUT.
I HAPPEN TO LOVE THE PRODUCT.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT?
IT'S A NEW TWIST ON SOMETHING
THAT EVERY KID IN AMERICA
BUYS EVERY OTHER YEAR.
AND ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS
I WANTED TO POINT OUT --
WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
I'M STILL TALKING.
THIS IS A SAD CASE,
QUITE HONESTLY, NO OFFENSE --
NO, IT'S FINE. YOU'RE FINE.
TO EITHER OF YOU --
THE RIGHT PRODUCT,
BUT THE WRONG ENTREPRENEURS.
I'M OUT.
OKAY, I GET IT,
YOU JUST GOT THIS PRODUCT,
AND YOU'RE TRYING
AND YOU'RE HUSTLING
AND YOU'RE TRYING TO GET IT
INTO A LOT OF PLACES.
THE PROBLEM IS, WHEN YOU SAY
THAT YOU'RE IN THAT MANY
STORES...
SURE.
...AND YOU'RE ONLY DOING
$10,000,
UNFORTUNATELY,
WHETHER ANY OF US THINK
IT SOUNDS LIKE A GOOD IDEA,
THE CONSUMER IS SPEAKING.
RIGHT.
AND THEY'RE SAYING
THEY DON'T WANT IT.
AND FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHTY.
GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW LONG
THE VESTPAKZ HAS BEEN AROUND.
IT'S A GREAT PRODUCT,
AND --
AND VESTPAKZ IS ON THE WAY
TO THE TOP.
♪♪♪
I'M ELLIE.
I'M BECCA.
AND WE ARE SISTERS
AND BEST FRIENDS.
GROWING UP, ELLIE AND I
WERE ATTACHED AT THE HIP.
AND THEN WE, YOU KNOW, GOT
MARRIED, HAD OUR OWN FAMILIES.
THIS BUSINESS HAS AFFORDED US
THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PURSUE A DREAM TOGETHER.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THESE
DOTS AND THE CHEVRON TOGETHER?
LOVE IT.
WE'VE CREATED A PRODUCT
THAT'S THE PERFECT ACCESSORY
TO ADD FUN TO ANY EVENT.
WHO WANTS SOME CAKE?!
[ CHILDREN SCREAM PLAYFULLY ]
WE LIKE TO SAY THAT
WE TAKE FUN SERIOUSLY.
GIMME A KISS,
GIMME A KISS.
AND IN AN ALL-TOO-SERIOUS
WORLD,
OUR PRODUCT WILL REALLY
PUT A SMILE ON YOUR FACE.
I NEED SOME WATER ON IT.
HAVE SOMEBODY LICK YOU.
ULTIMATELY,
WE'VE SACRIFICED A LOT.
WE'VE PUT IN $180,000.
WE'VE TAKEN A LOT OF QUALITY
TIME FROM OUR FAMILIES.
IT'S BEEN HARD, BUT WE KNOW
IT'S WORTH IT.
WE JUST NEED A LITTLE HELP
TO GET OUR NAME OUT THERE
AND MAKE IT AVAILABLE
EVERYWHERE.
[ LAUGHS ]
♪♪♪
HEY THERE, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS ELLIE BROWN.
AND I'M HER SISTER,
BECCA NELSON.
WE'RE ASKING FOR $100,000
FOR A 30% EQUITY STAKE
IN OUR BUSINESS,
evREwares.
HANG ON TO YOUR NOTEBOOKS,
SHARKS,
'CAUSE WE'RE ABOUT TO SHOW YOU
WHERE YOU CAN STICK IT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WE DESIGN AND MANUFACTURE
WEARABLE FABRIC
STICKER ACCESSORIES
THAT ADD INSTANT FUN
TO ANY OCCASION,
LIKE OUR FLAGSHIP PRODUCT,
THE STICKY TIE.
WELL, BASICALLY A STICKY TIE
MAKES AN ORDINARY T-SHIRT
EXTRAORDINARY.
[ PEELS ]
HUH.
THEY'RE REUSABLE,
THEY WON'T TEAR,
OR LOSE THEIR SHAPE.
PLAIN WHITE T-SHIRT...
PARTY SHIRT.
[ LAUGHS ]
PLAIN WHITE T-SHIRT...
INSTANT BLACK TIE FORMAL.
AND IF YOU HAPPEN TO SPILL
SOMETHING ON THEM,
THEY CAN BE WIPED CLEAN
AND WORN AGAIN
AND AGAIN AND AGAIN.
OKAY, BACK TO BUSINESS.
Robert: [ LAUGHS ]
[ CLEARING THROAT ]
SHARKS, WE HAVE SOME SAMPLES
THAT WE'VE PUT TOGETHER
JUST FOR YOU.
HERE YOU ARE, ROBERT.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
KEVIN.
YOU GOT IT. BARBARA.
THANK YOU, ELLIE.
Ellie: AND MARK.
I LOVE THIS.
NICE.
WHAT DOES IT SAY, LORI?
IT SAYS, "I'M A HERO,
NOT A ZERO."
HEY, LORI, "KISS ME,
I'M CROATIAN."
[ LAUGHTER ]
COME ON, LORI --
THAT'S CUTE!
WHAT IS THAT?
IT'S KEVIN ON MONEY.
I LOVE IT. I REALLY LIKE THAT.
THIS IS GONNA BE
YOUR BEST SELLER,
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
Lori: VERY CUTE.
WE'RE VERY PROUD OF THAT.
WHAT ARE THE SALES, BECCA?
SO TO DATE, WE HAVE ABOUT
$600,000 IN SALES.
UM, FROM 2011
THROUGH 2014 --
HOW ABOUT THIS YEAR?
WHAT ABOUT THIS CALENDAR YEAR?
THIS YEAR IS
A DIFFERENT YEAR FOR US.
UH-OH.
THIS IS -- THIS IS
WHY WE ARE HERE.
LAST YEAR WE HAD
MAJOR TRACTION.
WE LITERALLY WENT UP
TO $300,000.
WE SOLD INTO PARTY CITY,
THE CONTAINER STORE,
STEIN MART --
AND THEN TRAGEDY STRUCK.
Lori: ARE YOU STILL
IN THOSE STORES?
I JUST HAVE TO ASK.
NOT TRAGEDY.
WELL, WE STRUGGLED WITH
THE RATE OF SELL-THROUGH,
UM, BECAUSE IT'S SUCH
A BRAND-NEW CONCEPT.
THAT'S PART OF THE GLORY
OF IT,
BUT IT'S ALSO
A CONSUMER-AWARENESS ISSUE.
IT GOT DELISTED.
THEY DIDN'T TAKE IT
OFF THE SHELVES.
IT'S ACTUALLY
SELLING THROUGH,
JUST NOT AT THE SPEED
THAT THEY WOULD REORDER.
SO WHAT WILL YOUR SALES BE
THIS YEAR?
RIGHT NOW WE'RE ON PACE TO DO
ABOUT $50,000 THIS YEAR.
D'OH!
WHOA!
BUT LIST-- BUT WE HAVEN'T
GOTTEN TO --
HERE'S THE DEAL.
PULL UP! PULL UP!
WE ARE TRYING
TO FIGURE IT OUT, GUYS.
WE WENT BACK IN.
WE REDID ALL --
I THINK THE MARKET HAS SPOKEN.
THEY DON'T LIKE IT.
I DON'T THINK SO. BECAUSE --
NO, I DON'T THINK SO.
WHY ARE YOUR SALES
ONLY $50,000 THIS YEAR?
BECAUSE WE MADE
A CONSCIOUS DECISION
AT THE END OF THE YEAR
TO SLOW OUR ENGINES DOWN
AND FIGURE IT OUT.
WE DECIDED TO -- TO --
TO TAKE OUR FOOT OFF THE GAS.
NO!
HOLD ON,
NOT COMPLETELY OFF THE GAS.
REGROUP.
WE HAD TO.
BECAUSE IT WAS TIME
FOR 2014 TO BEGIN,
IT'S GO FAST,
MAKE YOUR CATALOG,
YOU DO THIS, GET THIS,
SPEND ALL THE MONEY GOING
TO THE TRADE SHOWS.
BECCA, IT'S NOT WORKING.
THINK ABOUT IT.
YOU -- YOU PUT IT OUT THERE.
YEP.
YOU HAD DECREASING SALES
YEAR AFTER YEAR.
YOU'RE DOWN TO 50--
DECREASING?
WELL, COME ON, YOU'RE DOWN
TO $50,000.
THAT WAS BECAUSE
WE CHOSE TO DO THAT.
WE COULD HAVE GONE OUT
AND SEEN --
NOBODY CHOOSES TO SEE
A BUSINESS DIE A HORRIBLE DEATH.
WHEN YOU ARE SELF --
YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE'RE FROM THE SOUTH,
AND YOU KNOW WHAT WE SAY
IN THE SOUTH?
"OH, BLESS HIS HEART.
HE JUST DOESN'T GET IT."
YEAH, BLESS HIS HEART,
THEN KICK HIS BUTT.
YOU'RE GOING TO ZERO!
OKAY, WELL, LET ME JUST
TELL YOU.
CAN I ASK YOU --
I HAVE QUESTIONS.
ASK HER IF SHE'S GOING TO ZERO.
WHAT DOES THIS TIE SELL FOR
AT THE RETAIL LEVEL?
CURRENTLY, THEY'VE BEEN
SELLING FROM $4.99
ALL THE WAY UP TO $7.99.
FOR ONE TIE?
FOR ONE TIE.
FOR ONE TIE. THAT'S RIGHT.
Mark: OH!
NO!
WHY ARE THE COSTS SO HIGH?
IT IS HIGH.
BECAUSE IT'S SOMETHING
THAT YOU CAN REUSE
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
THE MATERIAL ITSELF IS
A PREMIUM STICKER PRODUCT.
BECCA, JUST TELL US
WHAT IT COSTS YOU TO MAKE IT.
WE CAN GET IT DOWN TO 50 CENTS,
PACKAGED AND READY TO GO.
EXPLAIN TO ME
HOW THIS IS MADE.
THE, UM, MATERIAL --
IT HAPPENS TO BE
THROUGH AN EXCLUSIVE
SUPPLIER OF THIS MATERIAL.
IT'S PATENTED, AND SO WE HAVE
AN AGREEMENT WITH THIS SUPPLIER.
YOU'RE THE MOST EXPENSIVE
STICKER IN THE PARTY STORE.
I'M NOT GONNA PAY THAT KIND
OF PRICE FOR SOMETHING
I KNOW I'M THROWING OUT
IN THE MORNING.
I'M GONNA GET STICKERS
FOR 99 CENTS.
AND THEN YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
SOMETHING THAT IN THE END
IS PEELING OFF,
NOT STAYING STUCK.
AND YOU'VE NEVER BOUGHT
A WEARABLE STICKER --
I DON'T CARE.
I'M THROWING IT OUT.
IT'S DEAD, IT'S GONE.
NOBODY CARES.
I THINK 99% OF THE MARKET
DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT THE FACT THAT IT LASTS
A LIFETIME. WHO CARES?
YOU KNOW, SEVERAL YEARS BACK,
I INVESTED IN SOMETHING
VERY SIMILAR.
AND IT WAS REALLY DIFFICULT.
PEOPLE DIDN'T WANT TO REUSE
THESE THINGS.
THAT WAS THE PROBLEM.
I'M OUT.
I LOOK AT YOU,
ELLIE AND BECCA,
AS ENTREPRENEURS
THAT HAVE GONE THROUGH
A 3-YEAR PROCESS.
THE MORE TIME YOU SPEND ON IT,
THE MORE YOU'RE WASTING
YOUR PRODUCTIVE TIME.
BECAUSE YOU'RE GOOD ENOUGH
AND YOU'VE PROVEN
THAT YOU CAN BUILD BUSINESSES.
BUT YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE
A BETTER IDEA.
THIS IDEA SUCKS.
THIS IS A HOWLING DOG FROM HELL.
I'M OUT.
[ GASPS ] OKAY --
DON'T BEAT AROUND THE BUSH.
I RESPECT YOUR OPINION,
BUT WE REALLY DO --
YOU MUST LISTEN TO ME.
I'M LI--
I'M YOUR FRIEND HERE.
WE WANT TO BE SPONGES.
WE WANT TO LEARN FROM YOU GUYS.
BUT YOU HAVEN'T LEARNED ENOUGH
FROM YOUR THREE YEARS OF ISSUES.
Barbara: LADIES.
YES?
YOU LOVE DESIGNING, BUT YOUR
EYE'S NOT ON THE BUSINESS.
WORK WITH US. TEACH US.
WE'LL LEARN.
I'M OUT.
Robert:
[ CLICKS TONGUE ] ELLIE, BECCA.
REUSABLE, REWEARABLE,
TEAR-PROOF, RESIDUE-FREE --
NOBODY CARES.
I'M OUT.
OKAY. THANK YOU,
ROBERT.
DO YOU HAVE A WEB SITE
AND DO YOU SELL ONLINE?
WE DO.
'CAUSE YOUR NAME SUCKS.
Both: [ LAUGH ]
WHAT, evREwares?
'CAUSE YOU CAN REWEAR ---
YEAH.
Kevin: I THOUGHT OF GLASSES.
Robert: WE ARE SO POSITIVE
TODAY.
IT'S FANTASTIC BEING HERE,
GUYS. UM...
THIS IS SO AMAZING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WE REALIZE THAT WE'VE
HIT A HURDLE,
AND WE'RE WANTING
TO JUMP OVER IT.
WE'RE HAVING SO MUCH FUN
DOING IT.
WE LOVE --
OKAY, I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
AN OFFER.
WHY?
OKAY.
$200,000...
FOR THE ENTIRE BUSINESS.
MNH.
FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
MARK IS ELLIE AND BECCA'S
LAST CHANCE AT MAKING A DEAL
FOR THEIR WEARABLE FABRIC
STICKER COMPANY, evREwares.
OKAY, I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
AN OFFER.
WHY?
OKAY.
$200,000...
FOR THE ENTIRE BUSINESS.
MNH.
BECAUSE YOU GUYS ARE LOST.
RIGHT?
YOU GUYS ARE DESIGNERS.
WHERE IT MAKES SENSE,
I'LL CONTRACT YOU GUYS.
YOU'VE GOT A NICE LITTLE
SETUP BUSINESS.
YOU'VE GOT ACCESS TO RETAIL.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
BUT I THINK BY LOSING US,
IN THE PROCESS,
YOU'RE --
YOU'RE LOSING PART OF --
I CAN STILL CONTRACT YOU
FOR YOUR DESIGNS.
MARK, CAN'T YOU SET THIS UP
YOURSELF FOR 100 GRAND?
WHAT DO YOU NEED THIS --
ANY OF THIS FOR?
NO, IT WOULD COST ME MORE
THAN THAT TO SET IT ALL UP.
WHY?
CAN WE CHAT FOR A BRIEF SECOND?
SURE.
OKAY, THANKS.
WOW, I WOULD NOT CHAT TOO LONG.
ARE YOU NUTS?
THIS IS A PIECE OF CRAP.
MARK, IT IS A TOUGH BUSINESS.
IT'S A PIECE OF CRAP!
OH, I KNOW, BUT I CAN JUST
USE IT FOR JUST MAVERICKS STUFF.
OH, IT'S CRAP!
YOU COULD DO THIS FOR 50 GRAND.
IT'S NOT A GOOD DEAL.
[ LAUGHS ] WE'RE -- IT'S
$200,000 AND WE'RE DONE.
BUT YOU HEAR THE FEEDBACK
WE GOT.
WOW, GOSH. I DON'T KNOW.
[ CHUCKLES ]
OKAY.
WE COULD BE HOME MORE
WITH OUR KIDS
AND PAY ATTENTION TO THEM AGAIN.
I KNOW.
[ BOTH LAUGH ]
Y'ALL...
GOSH!
WHAT ARE WE DOING?
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT WE'RE
DOING AS WE'RE WALKING IN HERE.
[ FOOTSTEPS APPROACH ]
UM --
SEE --
HOLD --
I JUST WANT TO SET THE TABLE.
OKAY.
BECAUSE IT'S A VERY INTERESTING
MOMENT IN "SHARK TANK" HISTORY.
EVERYBODY HATES YOUR BUSINESS
AND PASSED.
THAT WE'RE ABOUT TO GIVE AWAY
OUR COMPANY FOR $200,000?
THEN MARK LOOKED AT YOU
AND SAID, "LOOK,
"YOU HAVE NO VALUE TO ME
IN THE CURRENT CONFIGURATION,
BUT I'LL BUY
THE WHOLE BUSINESS."
MM-HMM.
SO YOU HAVE TO MAKE
A DECISION --
$200,000
FOR THE WHOLE BUSINESS,
PASS EVERYTHING OVER TO MARK
TO RUN IT.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
[ MUTTERS INDISTINCTLY ]
WELL, I FEEL A REALLY
GREAT SADNESS RIGHT NOW,
BECAUSE WE REALLY DO
LOVE THIS.
WE'VE PUT A LOT INTO IT.
UM...
WE HAVE A TON TO OFFER.
SO...
WE -- BECAUSE WE DO
EVERYTHING.
I'M REALLY TEARING UP.
I KNOW. FROM --
Robert: ELLIE --
'CAUSE YOU DON'T WANT
TO LET IT GO.
I'M ONE OF THOSE STUPID PEOPLE
WHO CRIED ON TV.
I CRIED ON NATIONAL TV.
BUSINESS IS TOUGH. TEARS ARE NOT
GONNA HAVE ANY VALUE --
HANG ON, KEVIN --
I DON'T WANT YOUR SYMPATHY.
Lori: THEY'RE PEOPLE.
Robert: KEVIN, LET THEM TALK.
COME ON!
LET THEM TALK!
I MEAN, THIS IS A BIG
MOMENT, RIGHT?
LIKE, THIS HAS BEEN
THREE YEARS OF, YOU KNOW --
I THINK MY DAUGHTER
WAS IN --
SHE WAS 4
WHEN WE STARTED THIS.
YOU KNOW, LIKE HER FIR--
WHAT--
OHH.
IT'S JUST,
WE'VE DONE A LOT, AND --
AND WE KNEW NOTHING
ABOUT THIS, AND IT'S --
WE'VE COME SO FAR.
AND WE'VE LEARNED SO MUCH.
TO HAVE THAT MANY RETAILERS
TO SAY, "WE LOVE YOU,"
AND YOU GUYS ARE RIGHT.
HOW CAN THEY BE WRONG?
BECCA.
YES?
I HAVE TOTAL RESPECT
FOR WHAT YOU'VE --
SO I JUST HAD TO --
I HAD TO VENT.
WE JUST HAD TO GET IT
OFF OUR CHEST.
IT'S YOUR BABY
AND I RESPECT THAT, THAT'S WHY
I HAVEN'T SAID A WORD.
IT'S NOT AN EASY DECISION,
AND I RESPECT THAT.
IT'S NOT.
IS IT TIME TO LET OUR BABY GO?
I THINK IT IS.
[ SNIFFLES ]
WE'LL DO IT.
OKAY.
Sharks: WOW.
Lori: OHH!
Robert: OHH!
Lori: OH, THEY'RE CRYING.
Robert: I FEEL SO --
Kevin: BETTER THAN NOTHING.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU GUYS
THE GOOD NEWS, RIGHT?
IF I CAN TAKE THIS AND REALLY
TURN IT INTO SOMETHING,
I PROMISE TO TAKE GOOD CARE
OF YOUR BABY
AND DO THE BEST I CAN
TO RAISE IT
FROM THE DEAD AND TURN IT
INTO SOMETHING SPECIAL.
Ellie and Becca: THANK YOU.
OKAY?
THANK YOU, GUYS, SO MUCH.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS, THANKS.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE GONNA
BE DOING 24 HOURS FROM NOW?
CRYING BIG TEARS OF RELIEF,
AND YOU'RE GONNA APPRECIATE
THAT YOU GAVE YOUR KID
TO A GREAT GUY.
I SOLD MY COMPANY
FOR $5.7 BILLION...
I KNOW.
AND I WAS SAD WHEN I SOLD IT...
FOR ABOUT A MINUTE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I THINK THAT'S
A LITTLE DIFFERENT, MARK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ALL RIGHT, THANKS, MARK.
GREAT ENDING. WOW.
WE JUST CRIED...A LOT.
WE JUST CRIED. [ LAUGHS ]
THE LAST THING
I EXPECTED TO DO
WAS TO WALK AWAY FROM
THE COMPANY, AND I STILL --
I'M GONNA HAVE A HARD TIME
SLEEPING TONIGHT. [ CHUCKLES ]
IT'S REALLY HARD TO KNOW WHAT
TO DO IN THAT MOMENT, BUT --
BUT WE'RE EXCITED.
YEAH.
CAN'T YOU SEE?
WE'RE EXCITED TO SEE IT GO --
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED --
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED
TO SEE IT GO SOMEWHERE.